please be with you welcome to the D show
thank you for tuning in every week we
got exciting guests exciting topics and
this is no exception we have former Def
Jam artists here in the studio Def Jam
started by Russell Simmons he performed
or was working with the likes of Keyshia
Cole Bruno Mars and he's here to tell us
because he was getting paid back then to
make you dance he was the one that you
were hearing in the nightclubs and he
was doing things opposite to what he's
doing today he didn't have peace back
then he's charging the heart with what
he's going to be talking about today and
this week's show it's so important that
you tune in because this is how you're
going to benefit from the experiences of
our guest today if you're really a music
lover make sure that you don't go
anywhere here in the Dean show with my
next guest former Def Jam artist what
surprised you with him when we come back
don't go anywhere
welcome to the DS show peace be with you
sonic own body comes around what allow
you a better kisser
how you been how's that I introduced you
former Def Jam artist for people that I
don't know tell us about what is this
Def Jam Def Jam is a as a we're very
well known record label especially was
very well known for its hip-hop artists
back in the day such as rum Run DMC LL
Cool J these are some of the artists
that wore on their back in the day so a
lot of people know for that now we've
had you on the show before and we talked
about how people go back to the Dean
show calm to watch this program that we
did and you were getting paid I mean to
be their entertainment in a nightclub
you were singing the nightclubs correct
yes
yeah but I'm now you I mean before we
cut out on that last show we did with
you you were actually you weren't
singing and and we're not talking about
the singing you know that these are the
the natural sounds the birds and the
bees and nature and whatnot and the
human voice we're talking about you know
these things that are calling the human
being to corruption right and but you
left off reciting the Quran so now
you're also doing a quran project it
went from now getting paid to make
people dance exactly and how was the
heart back then Eddie the art you know
you you the heart itself is searching
for the truth sometimes without the
individual realizing it but what happens
is that we become so busy and I was just
having this conversation with another
brother about how Shaitaan makes us so
busy in our lives you know whether it be
with music once again movies you're
watching you know people that are glued
to the TV literally becoming a zombie we
become so busy in our lifestyle that we
don't realize the heart is literally
screaming out it's screaming for
guidance so the difference between my
heart then announce it's no comparison
I'm telling you like anyone that knew me
before and knows me now they see a big
difference you know and it's missing not
to brag about myself or anything but the
is this this is the calmness and the
peace that I have or the loss of handle
with Ajala today is it's it's a big
difference and I can I can't say enough
to be grateful you know I can't say
enough to think a lot honestly man I
mean I think about it every day how
Allah literally took me away from that
environment I was around literally if I
wanted to right now you know I'm someone
that can go right back to what I was
doing again and in literally with all
this technology today and make millions
of dollars without a record label you
know it's it's I'm just talking about
how it's so much easier to do those
things but I know in my heart cuz all
those things are temporary enjoyments
and they're gonna do nothing but destroy
me it's as simple as that
to simplify it's going to absolutely
destroy me and that's what I was on a
path of destruction without a doubt
without a doubt and that's the
difference when we say guidance now you
don't because many people they construe
you see a lot of weird things associated
with man-made religions absolutely and
we know that it's Lama submissions that
are created on the croatian is divinely
sent absolute and it makes sense it's a
logical way of life it just fits with
what you have inside that rigor is now
that knows that this is the truth and
you wouldn't sell I mean this way of
life now that brings that peace
contentment and happiness you're
experiencing it now which you weren't
obviously before it's temporary delights
and enjoyment so now when we talk about
this guidance and I'm gonna ask you this
question now because people think okay
now I got the ghost in me the spirit and
people dance and jump and doing all sort
of weird things and can get turned off
intellectual people get turn out but
guidance is not you can see straight you
see things for what they they are the
counterfeit gold the counterfeit dollar
you see is counterfeit this counterfeit
lifestyle is fake absolutely now you're
on the real way absolutely talk about
this this with how build up how people
are many people they don't see that
bismillah alhamdulillah wa salatu
wassalam are so they love many people
don't see that and this is people don't
understand this is one of the importance
of seeking knowledge the importance of
seeking knowledge is so that you worship
your Creator upon clarity like you say
that gives you that clarity you're able
to see the the false from that which is
real
you understand and that brings us to a
point when I was about 17 someone told
me I had a cross I had a cross on my
neck when I was about 17 and one of my
friends told me you have that you have a
catheter crossing your neck and I said
what do you mean I said what's the
difference I didn't have knowledge so
that lightbulb I had that lightbulb
effect that people talk about and so I
started to read the Bible I started to
ponder on the Bible myself which we
mentioned that most people don't do why
because of that that hypnosis effect
that they have that hypnotic effect that
they're under by because you jumping
dancing hopping around and so when a
person goes to read the Bible you fall
asleep because now you're in search of
knowledge so finding that knowledge
searching for that knowledge myself
first I see that what Jesus worships the
creator Moses worship the Creator what
was in his Aaron falling on their face
and worshiping the Creator Jesus peace
be upon him saying the one that sent me
is greater than I the one that sent me
is greater than all I said hold on I
want to worship who they're worshiping
so this gives once again knowledge
equals clarity as you mentioned as
simple as that now this is my next
question not to disparage on any
religion or anybody but we know the
message was clear what all these
messages came with but use mentioned the
cross and we know that Jesus peace be
upon him he had nothing to do with
calling people to worship him he called
people to worship the Creator because he
was sent by the crew but now you see a
lot of these celebrities and a lot of
these musicians they're doing everything
opposite to what he caught he call
people to chastity to morality and away
from this immorality but you've got this
big cross on your on your chest
many of these musicians and they're just
inviting people to all sorts of
scandalous evil things what are your
comments on this my comments on that is
that once again misguidance Eddy just
like myself I was somebody that had a
cross on my neck used to walk around
with these things but it was more like
you felt like it's some type of good
luck symbol kind of thing more
superstition is more superstition like
as you can see and myself as well as
many others they
know what that stands for they don't
have the knowledge that comes along with
it okay what what is the belief system
that comes along with it we didn't know
majority I would say the majority of
Christian brothers and sisters they
don't they just don't know they don't
have knowledge of with their parents of
following and that was me I was in those
shoes I didn't have knowledge of of the
Bible I didn't have knowledge of Jesus
peace be upon him itself or our belief
system and so once you have these are
this is just misguided so once again
they're wearing it I believe that what
many of them are wearing it for the same
reasons I was yeah we're gonna be right
there family be right back with more
former Def Jam artists here in a Deen
show don't go anywhere
please subscribe to the Biggio follow us
on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show so from working with
Keyshia Cole Bruno Mars had you get a
chance to talk about now that you change
your life there's usually amongst
musicians who've just filled their heart
with music constantly drugs alcohol and
you see a lot of them committing at when
they rise to the top you see there's no
peace there really the heart is yearning
for some house and they commit suicide
antidepressants drugs alcoholism and and
this is a actually there's a statistic
that it's it's much higher suicide rate
is much higher amongst famous writers
and artists this is known as statistic
tell us now did you get a chance to
relay some of this information to them
yes I've have spoken with a few friends
of mine within the music industry and
some of them know Islam is the truth you
know I haven't personally got the chance
to see I haven't seen Bruno in a long
time it's been a few years since I've
seen him Keyshia haven't seen her in
years also because I kind of like
drifted off of the scene but now since
I've been back here in the US there's
people that I want to reach out to again
and really talk to them because I know
they're many people are starving for the
knowledge so a lot of them yes I've had
the opportunity to give them dower
and invite them to Islam and I believe
many of them know Islam is the truth
fact one of my friends who was he was
the A&R Warner Brothers at the time on
Motown you know he know it's Nam is a
true but that lifestyle becomes a fitna
for them becomes a trial where they they
see they okay if I embrace Islam was
listen X kind of thing you understand so
it and there's a lot of singer musicians
out there who are Muslim but it's very
difficult for them to get away from that
lifestyle also and it's very difficult
for them to come out publicly and
publicly and say who they are you know
so they deal with that as well what
advice you know when you see a lot of
the the youth out there and you know
some are practicing not so practicing
some have a problem committing so much
but then when you diagnose their life
you'll see that they are addicted to
music is this a hinderance from you
being more of a complete worshiper to
the crater being addicted to music yeah
is it a hindrance absolutely without a
doubt because as I mentioned before the
statement of the man I'll claim josiya
rahim who law you mentioned that the
quran and music and it can't be in the
same heart at the same time you can't
love music and love the quran at the
same time they're they're gonna be at
war with one another so you know it's
it's definitely a hindrance you know you
may not a person may not feel the same
when they were citing in the salah it's
a big difference you know it may it may
make you hate listening to lectures and
things like that a person that's
addicted to music you know when a person
is dying they may be singing a song
instead of reciting the Kalima it's very
dangerous very dangerous so while i take
a chance while i take a chance on
something and there's something when you
know we know that is definitely a trial
without without a doubt is more
addictive than probably drinking alcohol
or is more addictive than than than then
trying to get away from smoking
cigarettes or things like it's more
addictive than it i believe it so it's a
step by step process
no one's gonna probably get rid of it
all all you know you know all at once
but take the steps necessary show a lot
of that you know
you're at least taking the steps you
know you know Allah is most forgiving
most merciful so and and and most
importantly I would say with that it's
to ask Allah to assist us when we have
those addictions ask just asks Allah
actually created to assist you ask Allah
for guidance even if we're not Muslim
for example the best thing we can do is
ask the creator of the heavens and earth
you know even if you don't believe that
the Creator exists say Oh God guide me
to that way which you are pleased with
guide me to your way without a doubt
Allah is gonna guide you to his land the
Creator is gonna guide you to Islam if
that person sincerely ask the creator of
the heavens and earth to guide them he
will guide them so likewise if a person
sincerely ask Allah to guide them away
from music they will without a doubt
Allah was system Allah will show them a
better way usually these kind of song
that you're singing this the RMB usually
men and as for our sisters I mean it's
LOM came to protect the woman elevate
the woman but you know through this
music this is another tool that men will
use to undress a woman absolutely and to
have his way with the woman isn't it
absolutely softens her up tell us about
this I mean this is something that is
used to soften like you said soften the
woman up women are very vulnerable in
the society as we see that there they're
used for for you know they're degraded
in the society already as we see so this
is another way you know from my point of
view to degrade women because once
you're able to to to to have them swing
and and and have them think in a certain
way you know it's there over for that
time they open for the attack and this
opens you up to on a deeper level to gym
possession and all kind of things when
we when we are becoming so aroused what
music it opens people up and that's a
whole nother topic in itself how people
become under possession without
realizing it because they are in a state
of this such a state of arousal or
you know whatever it may be this state
of arousing its opponent it just opens
you up for so many different things you
know we're gonna take a break we got
more a lot more to ask you here in the
Dean show with former Def Jam artists
someone who lived for music was getting
paid to make you dance now I'm a totally
different tune here on the DS show we
right back please subscribe to the
Biggio follow us on our official
Facebook and Twitter pages in the links
below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show I heard you mentioned
as before about the Jin position and I
missed a known fact that many of the
superstar celebrities you know they play
around the Ouija board
they tried desperately to make some
connection with the unseen world because
they desperately want to win that Grammy
they desperately want to achieve greater
heights so they'll connect they'll talk
to the okay you know spirit spooks and
whatnot the devils the jinns and Islam
clear this is one one path that you took
now exploring the unseen world on the
spirits that Islam clearly defines their
role and this is very interesting it's a
very interesting and kind of scary also
subject its Malad how many levels a lot
to assalamu artists to leela it people
don't understand like i mentioned when
you arouse yourself with these things
you're opening yourself up to a whole
nother world that people don't
understand and as you mentioned the
people the musicians playing with the
Ouija board people don't know what these
people are doing behind the scenes
there's a reason these these are these
women and these people are screaming in
the crowd for them they're utilizing
many people are utilizing the assistance
of the jinn to a system and their
performances and everything people don't
realize these things this is a whole
nother reality especially many of the
Muslims are very ignorant towards this
fact they don't understand that this is
a whole nother element it's just not
something that's you know friendly and
things like this no you are inviting
these things into your home on a deeper
level you know you're inviting these
things to your home and everything so
when you're talking about
the Djinn and these things like this
I'll give an example from a personal
experience Eddie I can tell you that
when I was a non-muslim as I mentioned
to you guys to play various instruments
I can tell you that it literally felt
like I was under possession I would do
things that I was not able to do I will
play things that I was not able to play
normally that I wasn't able to play
twice and people who musicians may say
oh this is the musician effect okay the
word genius comes from the word gin so
me and a brother in Egypt I remember we
were having this conversation he's a
brother than knew Jimi Hendrix he knew a
lot of people he's an old-school
musician and he said me and him were
playing around talking about the word
genius and stuff like this he said you
know he said when we say when we think
about the word genius we used to say we
used to think about that person has that
gin he got that jet reflect on this
people like Jimi Hendrix and he was not
able to play without being under a
substance being high without being high
so we know even from a scholarly point
of view whether the scholars mention
about people that get high and things
like this you make yourself open to what
the chin every musician that is on the
highest level think about it many of
them are doing drugs and alcohol to get
them to that level you can't escape it
you can you might as well if you don't
want to be involved with drugs and
alcohol or listening to someone that is
involved in those things you might as
well take all all of your CDs and
everything and just throw it out because
this is what the people that you're
listening to this is what they're
involved in many of them get in high
alcohol and as you mentioned it's am
clearly clarifies and make clear it
makes clear of the position on those
things so and when we talk about soul
music one of the people have people
listening to these terms soul music this
is something coming from someone's soul
so what state is that person in when
Neverland that the relay in those lyrics
to you or when they were singing that
song what state was the solar
you may start to feel the way that
person was feeling you understand this
is a serious thing this is a spiritual
thing you're talking about that's why
they know it they call it soul music
yeah
they say they flow terms out this is
magic in the making okay what magic are
you talking about yeah
tell us now you know the the young boys
young girls are young adults even now
they'll put on you know some music and
obviously the parents now they'll hear
the car sing and everything and they'll
obviously be turned off they turned that
off now it's got a new flavor so they'll
to throw on something that just seems
innocent cameras won't parents won't
catch on but tell us the effects here
because you got like groups like one
direction just Justin Bieber you don't
curse much but it's kind of the same
message here they're straight hardcore
get that duty you get that duty move be
be be be beep so now it's clear but over
here it's kind of those sweet words and
no cursing but at the end of the day
it's talking about committing
fornication you know losing the woman's
chastity tell us about this cover-up
here with the right it's it's arresting
because these songs may be cleaner but
still once again it goes right back to
the root it's still calling to the
disobedience of Allah like you as you
mentioned not being chaste like in this
society being a virgin is frowned upon
why it's because of what the people are
listening to what they're being
conditioned with they are being dumbed
down so I mean they're turning into
zombies so when you have these type of
songs they're still calling the youth to
the disobedience of Allah whether
whether were the children the youth are
starting to be very disrespectful to the
parents and the parents don't understand
why have you have you examined with what
they're allowed to listen to what do you
allow them to listen to so and I'll just
just a quick question
and everyone has the question this if
you listen to music if a person listens
to music ask them how many verses of the
Quran have them
is the Koran difficult for them to
memorize if so then you know why then
you know why I've met people in Egypt
brother Hedy and there was a brother
listening to music he was addicted to it
I saw he was addicted to it and accident
how many verses of the Quran had he
memorized how many Soros he had
memorized and he keep in mind that you
have many people to have memorized the
Quran in Egypt this brother had
memorized for Soros his whole life and
he told me I said I said have you been
listening to music since you were a
child
he said yes I've been listen doing this
listening to it and he said I'm addicted
to it you know I said this is the reason
this is the reason so anyone that has
the same problem look at just look at
the opposite the Quran and see how how
much time you spend with the Quran and
you'll see that Shaitaan is trying to
take you away from Allah clearly clearly
are you open now we've had guests on the
show before and people they like their
message they want to invite them to come
to their moisture to the University to
visit them are you open for giving such
absolute traveling and if someone wants
to get a hold of you how would they do
so absolutely what I'll leave my contact
details with you and thank you you have
a website or anything people go to us I
have our projects calm which is under
its under it's under construction right
now but they can still leave their email
and side of their that's um a our
projects PR o J e.t.s projects calm
o my projects calm beautiful and thank
you we're out of time but just uncle oh
hi thank you so much for being with us
and sharing your experiences and show a
lot the years got the benefit I surely
did thank you very much thank you
brother thank you and thank you thank
you for sitting tight throwing up
another episode of the dicho no time
lost former Def Jam artists here in the
Deen show went from working with the
likes of Keyshia Cole and Bruno Mars and
many others and he left that lifestyle
because he figured out the purpose of
life and now
filling the heart with what it needs and
we talked about that medicine that now
when you implement it in your life you
live by it you truly get that peace and
satisfaction what hinders people you can
have those songs playing all day and
night but at the end of the date or
temporary fixes temporary highs and then
at the end you got big-time crashes at
the end where did you go
you've been entertained with all these
sweet nothings and many of the young
ladies also end up using they're losing
their chastity and they end up running
towards this insanity and brothers end
up also doing some things that they
shouldn't be doing all an account of
listening to admiring the wrong people
listening to the wrong things but when
you go right with the advice that our
guest was given you won't go wrong you
won't go wrong so implement this advice
connect with the rate of word of God the
Quran ask your Creator the one who
created you for the support if you're
struggling having problems connect with
the salat lead off all of these other
nonsense alone and come back to the Deen
show subscribe if you haven't already
follow us like us on a Twitter Facebook
and now you can also join us on the
Instagram we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you please subscribe
to the Biggio follow us on our official
Facebook and Twitter pages in the links
below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below